[Music]  meagan Marcos said yes to a Givenchy  dress that now Duchess of Sussex looked  breathtaking walking down the aisle to  marry Prince Harry  Megan Wilde in white wearing classic 3/4  short puff sleeves and open neckline  emphasizing her shoulders and British  designer Claire way Keller had the honor  of designing her dream gown the stunning  bride pulled her hair back in a polished  updo and accessorize with Cartier  earrings and bracelet a dramatic five  metre long veil with floral trim held in  place by Queen Mary's diamond tiara her  wedding ring gifted by Her Majesty the  Queen and her engagement ring included  jewelry from the late Princess Diana's  collection but Megan sweet-ass accessory  future father-in-law  Prince Charles escorting her in her dad  Thomas Markel's place certainly Prince  Harry and Megan Markos royal wedding  breaks tradition in the best way  you  [Music]